مستشار الرئيس الاوكرانيا ان اي سيطره
محتمله للجيش الروسيه على سوليدار لن تحقق
لروسيا اي نتائج باستثنائيه رفع الروح
المعنويه لقواتها واضاف في مقابله
التلفزيونيه عند القوات الروسيه كشفت
هجاماتها على المدينه بسبب اخفاقها في
السيطره على باخموت منذ اربعه اشهر
انها عمليه مشتركه لقوات المدفعيه
والطيران الحربي الروسي لقد وضع المهاجمون
في مهمه انتحاريه لمواجهه الموت او التقدم
لهذا السبب تقدمه
الان من ثلاثه
محمود حاليا تحت السيطره الناريه
انهم يريدون تحقيق اي نصر على الارض هو
ثمن
على المدينه المدمره لن يحقق لهم اي
نتائجها باستثناء رفع معنويات جنودهم
الذين يخضعون قواتنا كان يصنده وفي غضون
ذلك اعرب المتحدث باسم الكريم لاند متر
بيسكوف عن استعداد بلاده لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه من خلال المفاوضات لكنه اكد ان
بواقفه اوكرانيا والغرب لا تسمح باجراء
محادثات في الوقت الراهن وفق تعبيره واضاف
بسكوف ان الضوء الى الغربيه بقياده
الولايات المتحده مستعده لمواصله داخل
اسلحه الى اوكرانيا لكن لما مخزناتها تنفذ
مشيرا الى ان بلاده تفضل تحقيق اهدافها في
اوكرانيا بالوسائل السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
كما قال بوسكوف ان هناك تقدما ايجابيا
للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا وان الحديث عن
النجاح العسكري ممكن بعد تحقيق اهداف
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه داعيا لعدم
التسرع في اعلان الانتصار في سوريا
امام تحرير كامل او تحرير كامل الاراضي في
دمباز
نقطه تحول في طريق اكمال بسطه سيطره على
كل الاراضي وان تحرير هذه المدينه مع
باخمود وسيفرست سيمكن القوات الروسيه من
تدميريه خط المواجهه على طول جبهه دمباز
تنظرينا من كيف مراسله الجزيره كاترين
حالنا ومن موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي ابدا بك امين درغامي وايضا هذه
التصريحات لبسكوف والحديث عن الانفتاح على
التفاوض
وانهاء المشكله بالطرق السلميه
وعدم اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه السيطره
على على سوليدار رغم اعلان فاكنادر ذلك
نعم زين تصريح بسكوف بخصوص تعداد روسيا
للمفاوضات في الحقيقه ليس جديده روسيا
كانت خلال هذه الاشهر الاخيره دائما ما
تعرب عن استعدادها للتفاوض لكنها في
المقابل تحمل الجانب الاوكرانيا المسؤوليه
عن عدم قيام هذه المفاوضات كما قال بسكوبا
اليوم فان القانون الاوكراني يمنع على
القياده اجراء اي اتصالات مع اجانب الروسي
بحسب قوله وايضا اتهم الغرب على راس من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانها تمنع
القياده الاخرانيه مما سماه ابراز اي
مرونه في مساله مفاوضات مع جانب الروسي
لكنه في المقابل قال بان روسيا ما زالت
مستعد رغم عدم وجود اي اشارات على قرب
اجراء اي ااه مفاوضات مع جانب همم
الاوكراني لكن بيسكوف طبعا شدد من جديد
على اهداف ما سماها العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا دعا الى عدم
التسرع في اعلان السيطره الكامله للقوات
الروسيه على سوليدار وهذا يعود على ان
الكريم دائما ما كان يحيل مساله التعليق
على الاوضاع الميدانيه الى وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه هذه هي الوزاره وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ايضا اصدرت بيانا اليوم قالت بان
طبعا المعارك ما زالت متواصله داخل مدينه
سوليدار بان القوات الجويه الروسيه شلنا
الضربات على نقاط تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
في هذه المدينه وعن ان القوات الانزال
الجويه تحاصر الان مدينه سوليدار من
الاتجاهين الشمالي والجنوبي بالنظر الى كل
هذه التصريحات زين نرى بان همم الوزاره لم
تعلن فقط السيطره عن مدينه سوليدار لكنها
في المقابله اكدت ما كانت فاجنر تحدث به
وما كان ايضا زعيما لانفصاليه في دنيا قد
اكده وهو ان ان القوات الروسيه الان تقوم
بتمشيط وسط
سوليدار وهذا طبعا لم ينفيه حتى الجانب
الاوكراني همم الان الاوضاع بات تقريبا
شبه واضحه هناك معارك ما زالت تدور داخل
مدينه همم سوليدار هذه المدينه بحسب
المعطيات الروسيه وبحسب ما لم ينفه الجانب
الاوكراني هي محاصره من محورين على الاقل
الشمالي والجنوب الجنوبي وبان اا طرق
الامداد الامداد الدعم العسكري الى القوات
الاوكرانيه باتت تحت السيطره الناريه
للقوات الروسيه طبعا هناك ايضا معطى اخر
يتعلق بما سماه زعيم الانفصاليه في دنياك
بمرحله تغيير او مرحله انتقال من وضع الى
تمثيله السيطره على سوليدار هذا طبعا
يحلنا الى تجدد المعارك واشتدادها في بعض
المناطق الاخرى خاصه حول بخمه ايضا في
مارينكا القريبه من دونياسكو هناك ايضا
التجدد المعارك حول اجدار التي كانت
القوات روسيه تحاول اقتحامها منذ نحو
تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر الى ان المعارك حول هذه
المدينه كانت قد توقفت الوزاره ايضا اكدت
على السيطره على بلده استراتيجيه مهمه
هذه البلده تقع الى الشمال من بخمه هذا
ربما يبرز
نيه عسكريه لدى اجانب الروسي من تقطيع
الطرق اي طرق الامداد بين سوليدار وبخمت
وبالتالي عزل ضخموت هذا طبعا يوفر لها
طريقا نحو مدن اهم من سوليدار وهنا الحديث
عن مدن كاسلا
طبعا الامير درغاميه نتحول الى كاترين حنا
من كيف
هنالك نفي للسيطره على
سوليدار من الجانب الاوكراني لكن لا يوجد
نافيه للتقدم الروسي لا يوجد نفي لدخول اا
قوات فاجنر الى قلب المدينه الى المركز
الاداري اليس كذلك
تؤكد ان معارك ضاريه
توصفحنا بالضاريه وحيدا بالعنيفه ما زالت
تدور في سوليدار ولكن ان في جاء تحديدا
على ان تكون قد تمت السيطره من قبل القوات
الروسيه على سوليدار هذا ما جاء على لسان
المتحدث باسم الجبهه الشرقيه الذي نفذ
تماما ان يكون هذا الخبر صحيحا واكد ان
بيان سوف يصدر بخصوص هذه التطورات في وقت
قريب لاحقا كله تصريحات الرسميه
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن استمرار هذه المعارك
اخرها بيان الصدر منذ قليل عن وزاره
الدفاع التي نقلت عن قائد القوات المحموله
جوا وهي قوات المظليين التي تتولى الدفاع
عن سوليدار نقل عنها انها ما زال نقل عن
قائدها انها ما زالت تدافع عن كل سنتيمات
بحسب قوله من ارضنا الاصليه وتحدث ايضا
بيان وزاره الدفاع خسائر كبيره بني بها
الروس كسبا على صعيد الاسلحه او على صعيد
القوه البشريه مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
اليوم ايضا عندما اتى على ذكر ما يجري
ويدور في سوليدار لم يتحدث عن اي سيطره
للقوات الروسيه بل اكد ان المعارك ما زالت
مستمره هناك حتى اخر لحظه وقال ان اي
خساره محتمله بحسب التعبير الذي استخدمه
في تصريحه في سوليدار لن تشكل ولن تكون
لها اي نتائج مهمه باستثناء انها قد ترفع
من معنويات الجيش الروسي لا غير هذا ما
همم اذا جاء على لسان المستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني علما ان الرئيس الاوكراني همم
نفسه وفي اخر تصريح له ليله امس ايضا لم
ياتي على ذكر سوري دار بشكل مباشر بل تحدث
عن دانيات بشكل عام وصف المعاركه هناك
بالصعبه طلب من وصفهم بالشركات همم يعني
دفع دعم
ورفع مستوى المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه
لبلاده معتبرا ان من سماها دول العالم
الحر همم تملك كل ما هو ضروري من اجل وضع
حد للعدوان الروسي كما قال على اوكرانيا
والحاق ما وصفه بالهزيمه التاريخيه
بروسيا لم ياتي على ذكر سوري دار الا
عندما شكر القوات التي تحارب هناك وتدافع
عنها على ما تقوم به من جهود من اجل همم
منع سيطره الروس على هذه المدينه اذا حتى
هذه اللحظه همم نفي اوكرانيا رسمي لان
تكون السيطره قد تمت على سوريدات ولكن كما
ذكرنا سابقا تاكيدا على ان معارك ضاريه
وخسائر ايضا كبيره في الارواح والاسلحه
بحسب ما يؤكد تؤكد السلطات الاوكرانيه في
صفوف القوات الروسيه في سوريا دار
وهذا ايضا ما يعني نفس الخط الذي اتخذته
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالاعلان عن وجود
قتال في سوليدار شكرا جزيلا لك منكي
مراسله الجزيره كاترين حنا ومن موسكو شكرا
لمين درغامي